- On this episode, we talk
about the supply and demand
of content, Twitter polls,
and do I compete with others
or myself.
(upbeat instrumental music)
♫ Gary Vee
♫ You ask questions
♫ And I answer them
♫ This is the #AskGaryVee Show ♫
- Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and this is episode 166
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
Just had a little fun
experimenting on Periscope.
How many people are back, 40, 50.
- [Voiceover] Approaching 400.
- Okay, that happens fast.
What's up everybody.
Glad to have you back.
I'll let you watch the show.
Thank you for that.
Before we just jumped
on Periscope at about
700 people early on
this Wednesday morning.
Pre-Thanksgiving big shout out.
Happy Thanksgiving to
everybody who's celebrating
it in the US.
Market, very quiet in the office today
as people are traveling
and getting home.
Thank you team for being here.
India, tomorrow for you?
You're flying tomorrow?
- [India] No.
- Today?
So you're staying.
- [India] I'm staying.
- So happy Thanksgiving to you guys.
And I decided to bang out a show early
this morning.
I have a new video out, a new movie.
Staphon, maybe you can play it in parallel
in an open space here for a few seconds
while we're talking.
This new movie speaks to
fitness entrepreneurs.
I think that there's a lot
of people in the fitness
entrepreneur space
hacking a lot of bull crap
on Instagram right now.
And I kinda wanted to call them out,
that they're putting in
the work for their abs,
their ass, and their muscles,
but they're not putting
in the work for their business.
I was pretty proud of it.
I hope you guys check that out.
Staphon, let's link that.
(tinkling)
In a Facebook and YouTube
and share that up.
I'm so fascinated by the share virality
in the Facebook environment
and wanna find new
audiences so I'm gonna
throw a right hook here.
If you like it and it's
relevant, please share that up
on your Facebook account.
India, good to see you.
I'm in a little bit of a
better mood this morning.
As a matter of fact, I may
even make a Jets prediction,
I decided.
And I really didn't think I was going to,
but some people motivated me.
Truth is I actually don't
know what's gonna happen.
You've got two teams that
are really struggling
in the Jets and the Dolphins.
And whatever, AJ is
here, it's good to see.
With a cage.
(laughs)
So India, I think today I'm a little bit,
I'm not a salty.
Yesterday was quite salty.
A lot of people liked it.
I didn't realized how
many people liked salt,
I mean--
- Salty Vee.
(laughs)
Hashtag Salty Vee.
- It's so easy with your name, so good.
- You know what's interesting?
I am scared to think
what the episode would
have been on Monday,
because I literally said
I don't want to do it,
which is the only time
since we started this show
that I didn't do a show
when I could have.
The only time.
If you thought I was salty on Tuesday,
imagine the salt.
I mean I was like.
(laughs)
I was like the, who's the
department that takes care
of stuff when it snows?
- [Voiceover] Sanitation.
- Sanitation, yeah.
Literally, the level of salt
that I was bringing on Monday
is like the New York city
sanitation department
before a 28-inch storm of snow.
I was real salty, so.
I know you guys enjoyed it on Tuesday.
Who know what the Monday version
of it would have been.
But India, let's get into the show.
All right.
- [India] Riley?
- Riley.
- [India] Do you think that content--
- (laughs) Sorry.
I'm in a better mood today.
- [India] Really hyper.
- [Voiceover] Riley asks,
"Do you think that content
"marketing is watering
down internet content
"with unimportant and false information?"
- Nope, I do not.
I think that crappy and false information
has always existed.
It exists every single
moment that you live.
The amount of crap and wrong information
that is gonna be spewed
at the dinner tables
across America tomorrow by family members
to each other, is staggering.
Uncle Rick is gonna pound his fist
about politics or about football
or about why Facebook is bad,
or a million other things tomorrow,
and so humans are really good at having
the ability to put out
crap and false information.
I think the Internet just
happens to be a place
where they dump that, and so I don't think
content marketing has changed the dynamic
that will be around forever.
My friends, one of the good things about
watching my show is you
can start picking up themes
because there's 20 to 50
pillars that I will play
over these 175 episodes I
plan on doing for the show
all time.
Kidding, kidding.
And I think the thing that would probably,
if you really pay
attention, you will pick up
on is I don't think
that many new things
are happening.
I just think that there's a current state
that then allows the
humans to do their thing.
And so yeah, I don't
think content marketing
has created a bigger supply of crap.
I think that supply of
crap has always existed.
We're just communicating
in different places.
You like that one, India.
- [India] Message not the medium.
- Message not the medium.
It's pretty consistent pillars.
- [Voiceover] John asks,
"After watching 165 episodes,
"I was wondering if you
get more satisfaction
"competing against
yourself or versus others?"
- I don't compete against myself at all.
It's why I struggled with fitness,
which I know I had a hard time.
Because I made a new fitness movie.
I don't know if you guys heard.
Staphon, you can put it right here and run
in parallel while I'm giving this answer.
I'll give you a little room for editing.
I'm really bad at competing with myself.
So I'm not trying to make this show better
in episode from 123 to
now, from 92 to now.
I always love myself, I'm
always thinking that it's good
and that I'm good.
I know it evolves, but I'm
not competing with myself.
I'm really bad at that.
Again, back to fitness, I
didn't want to run a minute
faster or have 20 more pounds.
That wasn't what it is.
I wrote a fitness article
about how I needed
to be accountable to somebody else.
That was my hack.
I'm very good, though with
competing against other people.
I hate everybody else
that's putting up business
content podcast and video.
I want to destroy them.
I hope all their podcast
equipment melts tomorrow.
And I wanna be the only person that talks
about business in the world left.
That's how I get all the audience.
I win, you lose, podcast McGee, yay.
So I think I compete against other people,
that's what drives me.
That's how I roll.
But I'm completely all
in, and me and my team,
the Jets have two or three former
Patriots on their team,
David Ridley, Thompkins
right now.
I love them with all my heart.
That logo goes off their
helmet, it goes somewhere else,
I despise them with all my heart.
I'm very on team me, team
my things that I like.
And I don't compete within that self.
I compete against
everybody else around it.
And it's funny.
It's how I handle VaynerMedia.
They're on my team, they're my employees,
I love them, even though I still love
the employees that once worked here.
Claire, a mutual friend of ours.
We love Claire so much.
I love Claire Stein, love
her with all my heart,
just not as much as I used to.
Because she wears the
New York Times logo now,
now the VaynerMedia one.
I can't help it.
I wanna destroy Claire now.
(laughs)
Claire, I love you.
But I wanna destroy you.
You know like, that's just the way it is.
That's the game mechanics.
That's how I think, and it's very real,
and it's interesting.
When you get to really fall
in love with an employee,
that has been with you, we had a couple
of that with us for two, three, four years
that are recently leaving,
and it's very painful for me,
I get sad.
Super lower lip.
Like lower lip.
But I wanna destroy their
faces the next moment.
Because they're putting
on a different jersey.
I just can't help it.
It's just the truth.
Yeah, but you know what's funny,
but I also, and you guys know this.
I still interact with them.
I help them with their
careers, so even though
I get pissed at players,
after they lose the game
they go shake the other team's hands,
I used to really get mad at that,
the truth is that I'm hypocrite,
because I do that, because I'm doing
that behind the scenes,
and so I felt compelled
to share that because I don't wanna
be a hypocrite.
It pisses me off.
I wish I didn't.
Like I wish I could hold
the line, but I don't
because I like them.
I love you, Claire.
But I hate you.
India.
- [Voiceover] Jared asks,
"Gary, do you have any questions
"that you don't know how
to answer for yourself?"
- Yeah, there are some
questions I don't know
how to answer myself.
The number one being,
when you pay forward,
when you take 15 minutes
to speak to a former
employee to help them with
their next career move
because they made a
mistake in leaving Vayner,
not you Claire, but like, you know,
I question if all these paying
forward, doing the right
thing, will I one day,
when I'm not the height
of my power and execution, or when I run
out of time and don't achieve the things
that I should have achieved,
or will I re-context
and say, cool, I made these things,
but I'm also a great person and everybody
showed up to my funeral, like I'm most
wondering, will I ever have a moment where
I become bitter or regretful
of the disproportionate
amount of non-value for
me, things that I do.
And the question really becomes,
which one am I more full of shit on,
that I wanna buy the New York Jets,
or that I want everybody
to show up to my funeral.
I've two very opposing pulling actions
in my life, which is, I
wanna be this very likeable
noble great dude that
everybody talks about
at the dinner table.
I want all of you, I
literally, this is so sick.
I desperately want the three of you
to like tell your
grandchildren about this great
man that you worked with.
I mean it.
I really do.
It's so important to me.
But to do that, you have
to do so many things
that are not in your
best interest financially
in the short term, and I'm just curious,
the thing that I don't
have answered for myself
is when I'm dying, and
I'd like to by the way,
I'd like to not suddenly die.
I prefer to die a little
bit slower so I can ponder,
because I like pondering.
When that's happening,
or at least I think so
so right now, maybe when I'm a hundred
and four, but (beeps) this.
Shoot me in the head, kids.
(laughs)
When I'm pondering it, I'm so curious.
Because one's gonna have to give.
I'm trying to walk the tightrope, and boy,
I think I'm really doing a solid job.
But I'm not sure, the
question I don't have answered
for myself is if I'm gonna like the way
I played it.
Because I'm consciously playing it.
I'm so in tune with
what's going on with me.
Am I gonna look back and be like,
good job?
Because everytime, I just turned 40,
I look back at 20 or 30,
I look back at 30 or 40,
and I guess that what
I'll probably always do,
because what's pretty
consistent now is there's
a lot good, there's things you'd nitpick.
I'm sure everybody does that.
The regrets, can I minimize the regrets.
Because I think having regret is the most
unfortunate thing.
Meeting a 70, 80, 90,
100 year old who regrets.
Regrets that they didn't have more fun.
Didn't spend more time with their family.
That's the cliche one.
But you'd be surprised how many people
regret not doing more for themselves.
So I don't know.
It's kind of intense.
That was quite real.
That was really real.
(mumbling)
Can I what?
What are you trying to growth hack here?
- [Voiceover] Well I'm curious.
- Well I'll give you an
update on the shares.
So earlier, by the way,
what I was referring
to in the beginning of the show,
is I asked a bunch of people to share
the content.
It was at 150 or what was it?
- [Group] 122.
- It was at 122, and then we went to
(mumbling)
It's 526, so it's quiet, I would say.
Cool.
- [India] Video from Rob.
- Video from Rob.
Bo knows.
- Gary Vee, Rob Cressy with Bacon Sports
in the house having a little Gary Vee
party over here.
Wanna know, what do you
think about Twitter polls?
The engagement, monetizing them,
drop some knowledge on me.
- (laughs) First of all,
the best part about Rob,
is no joke, that literally felt like.
Rob I'm gonna make a prediction.
You watched wrestling as a kid.
(laughs)
That was literally like a wrestling promo.
Rob's like, this Thursday
night at the Civic Coliseum,
Gary Vee and I are gonna throw
down some Twitter polls.
I think Twitter polls really work.
I've been getting a lot of engagement,
two or three that I've tested.
It's very simple.
Humans are basic.
They say like, do you think this person
should me president, yes or no?
They click the button,
the engagement is high,
monetizing them I think
is a long tail play.
You're not gonna monetize them, Rob.
Twitter will monetize them,
it's on their platform.
More engagement, they'll
run into their metrics
for you, for me, for
others, for all of us,
tt's an opportunity to engage our audience
on Twitter a little bit more often.
I think if you really get good at it,
you get clever with questions,
or win in a long tail niche,
there's some real opportunities.
So I think that, I think that.
I think that a very smart
Twitter poll strategy
for personalities on
Twitter is a very good
place to go, and a consistency to build
a cadence and a brand as
the pollster on the platform
is the only extreme upside.
For everybody else, it's a nice tactic.
So for four to five people in the world,
they'll break out as maybe
a pollster on the platform.
And for everybody else,
it's just a way to like,
get a little bit more
engagement out of your audience.
Though Twitter is not like
Facebook that engagement
then leads to a proxy of more
people seeing your tweets,
everybody seeing all of your content.
Maybe you win on less about
how many people will see it.
But people pay more attention to you
because your polls made
you interesting to them,
and now they're looking
at all your content.
So I think it's a very long
tail value prop for people.
- [Voiceover] Stefan asks,
"Gary, would you rather
"travel back in time to
meet your ancestors,
"or forward to meet your future relatives?"
- 100 thousand percent
go backwards and meet
my ancestors.
I'm also the by-product
of being unfortunate
in a place where I didn't get to know
three of my four grandparents,
which is on the low end
I think so that kind of stinks.
I knew two great grandparents,
which was awesome,
but they died very early on.
Actually, my great grandmother died later.
But great grandfather died when we first
got here, although I was very close to,
to this (mumbles).
And so I would go
backwards because I'd love.
The cool thing about, I meant they're both
cool, because the thing you look for,
it's all very selfish.
You're like, oh my god,
my great great great
granddaughter is so similar
to me, and like does things.
But for me, I don't know,
I like the backwards.
I'd like to see like my
grandfathers, to see what
they're like, see what I pulled from them.
My great great great
grandfather and grandmother,
I'd like see like, where
it came from for me.
And so that's what I would do.
Cool. That was it?
- [India] Yeah, that's everything.
- That's awesome.
That was a nice kind of family thing,
a very smart strategy Indy.
Was that your strategy?
Yeah, it was a very good smart strategy.
Have a wonderful, wonderful thanksgiving.
Really, really enjoy.
The question of the day is, where are you
going to share and spend your Thanksgiving
in the US market?
And for everybody outside the US market,
what do you think the Jets-Dolphins score
is going to be.
And then for everybody who has no idea
what American football is, just say hello.
Yeah.
Prediction.
13-12, Dolphins.
And I don't know, that's just,
it's just gonna be a crappy game.
I don't even know.
You know what, that's not a prediction.
That is not a prediction.
I know I said it, it's not a prediction.
Because I just said it.
It's no a real prediction.
I can't get motivated
to make a prediction.
I don't feel in tune.
I feel out of tune.
So there's no prediction.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
(bassy instrumental music)